I'm sup YouTube this is something that's
been on my heart for a long time and you
know all I ever wanted to be in life is
a Super Saiyan
Oh what's going on YouTube check it out
so I have seen some [ __ ] in my life and
I mean some [ __ ] but this tops all of it
this video is about a kid who thinks
that he could turn Super Saiyan for
those of you who do not know what Super
Saiyans are it's based off this Japanese
cartoon called granny ball and this kid
actually fixed that he can become one
how come I'm just a human being you know
Oh what can I do I can run I can jump I
can flip and it's just like we are so
limited as human beings limit it you can
run jump and flip [ __ ] I can't do
either of those let me tell you
something I wouldn't run even if the
competition I just dropped default like
this just for all I know you tell to the
cell the last thing I said was a pancake
like why can't I wake up and if I'm late
for school just teleport there and be on
time why can't you just wake up and
teleport and be on time well you're not
crazy
just the laziest [ __ ] in the
world instead of teleporting how about
you wake up and just show up on time if
you had the power to teleport you just
use it just show up on time you are the
sorriest superhero I've ever heard of my
life if I could tell bronze yeah I
probably want to be in school I probably
just open up own business called fast
shipping bestest Asian shipping today I
thought Chinese man sent a piece of
paper on fire well just as the power of
his hands is that it is it is this what
you saw that's it of course it sounds
absurd when you first look at it but if
you try it you know if you actually set
your mind to it and believe you can
achieve it Bruce Lee boy this is not
some kung fu trickery [ __ ] this is you
trying to turn yourself into a cartoon
this is the weird [ __ ] you're gonna
concentrate so hard but you're gonna
turn yourself into a yellow haired
blue-eyed white man you got some racial
issues you need a handle my brother he
channeled that energy from within and he
believed and he channeled that energy
due to creation of his mind but what his
mind believed and what he spoke into
existence you know what give you sense
of great words of wisdom
anything that you
Montu you can do it here's the problem
it has to be humanly possible even
Japanese people looking at you live East
never hop and eat do you know what you
just did now every single brother and
sister out there it's gonna hate us
ancient people and we just got back into
the black community with Jeremy Lin and
you done [ __ ] it up
my Stallman looking brother was it
necessary for you to take off your shirt
I think it would be more believable if
you kept your shirt on looking like
Everybody Hates Chris Super Saiyan fix
more like super slim fool the only thing
look like you were doing with the
beginning of a krumping routine just
[ __ ] that wasn't that's not cramping I'm
starting kick I'm not gonna hate on you
because everybody has dreams and
everybody should have dreams but here's
the problem
get your [ __ ] life together Oh kiss
your [ __ ] on some real life gold are you
gonna put this [ __ ] on your resume oh I
see well it says here that you um yeah
this is your a Super Saiyan that's right
down Super Saiyan
su p ER as I say you know how it is how
the hell are you gonna tell people what
to do with their life when you barely
hit puberty [ __ ]
the reason why I'm so upset is because
he has so many things that he could be
doing right now besides thinking about
shooting yellow flames at Miss [ __ ]
but instead he's thinking about the next
time he could turn himself into a
cartoon in the words of mockery and
uncle ah she - open your eyes a jackass
later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend right
growing up in a desert
he's another super saiyan